this weekend beheadings yeah basically
this one is actually not from Isis so
this one is in Saudi Arabia it's a
little unclear who is doing the
beheading here but this is a mass
beheading now this is insanely graphic
of all the beheading stuff that we've
done and all the stuff you're seeing
this one might be the worst so you are
warned and then we'll break it down
after here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so I was a little glib about the
beheading thing when we started this
thing obviously awful now this is Saudi
Arabian again it's a little unclear
what's happening but that's a mass
beheading in front of a group of people
none of those people are doing the
beheading or going to jail
Saudi Arabia is our ally by the way a
big Gulf state ally so I just want to
start there since since we don't know
the specifics of who's doing this or why
we do know this is out of Saudi Arabia
this was last week do we have a real
issue with Saudi Arabia that this is
about oil right where they can just do
whatever the they want what's that
you know I don't I think it's really
unclear why this is happening but I
think we what we do know is that it is
happening in Saudi Arabia is under
Sharia law and just in 2013 there were
about 79 beheadings public beheadings
that we know of and of those about half
of them were foreigners so it goes to
show that there are tensions underlying
this that affect us as foreigners as
well and I would love to have more
information on this because in this
particular case it could be anything
from rape to theft ooh to you we don't
know why this is occurring so we don't
know if it should be really or if it is
really politically charged in this case
right to me it seems like right now with
everything we see with Isis everybody
gets politically charged no matter what
the reasoning was and in this case it
could be it could not be regardless of
that I think the question to answer the
question that you're asking
of course our allegiance to Saudi Arabia
is because of oil yeah we don't make
allies because we find moral equivalency
between ourselves and these names of
crude oil we specifically have strategic
allies in the Middle East who can
deliver us oil and who can help us with
with military units to treat strategic
military bases places that we can reach
other areas I mean we're bombing Syria
right now we're involved in Afghanistan
and Iraq right now and the only reason
the only reason that we have maintained
a strong allegiance with Saudi Arabia is
because they give us very cheap oil this
is
obviously women can't vote there by the
way I was gonna say this is obviously
what happens when you have a theocracy
it doesn't have to be what happens when
you have a theocracy but this is you
know I can't help but make the point
that when religion and government are so
inextricably linked and when that
religion is one that that glorifies
violence and does it in the name of
Allah that what you end up seeing is
that rule of law doesn't matter that
you've got women who are subjugated and
that you've got I mean and I don't want
to claim moral superior superiority here
because in America we also have Kappa -
every time we say yeah we have capital
punishment we do the same thing in our
way we put to death criminals and that
is what they're doing in Saudi Arabia
they do it publicly they there's fanfare
around we don't know what those people
were tried with I'm assuming that was
the government that was that was doing
these beheadings I don't know but if it
were we do the same thing in many states
in our Union so like I guess a moral
superiority and every time we do these
kind of things we do terrible things we
do lethal injections that half the time
don't work we just have that one a
couple weeks ago the guy took a half
hour for him to die that being said I
guess there's something just so graphic
about this that I think you don't stone
women to death for you know you know
cheating on their husbands for example
and that's something that does happen
yeah in Saudi Arabia we allow women to
walk the streets not completely covered
up and not with male chaperones women
are allowed to drive they're allowed to
go to school you know these are things
that obviously in that sense I think I
can claim moral superiority I think I
think over that I'm pretty sure I think
so why do we have this weird moral
relevance with this stuff like when when
Russia was doing the anti-gay stuff
everyone went crazy we did a story two
weeks ago how Egypt is now cracking down
on gay people like if this happened in
in England of course but you know not in
the most Western country but somewhere
in between Saudi Arabia and England give
me a country like Qatar yeah we would
probably be less outraged you know I
mean like there's why how do we pick who
we're okay with doing what and why did
that
what you make any sense I think what
you're saying is what when do we care
and how do we choose Karen what what
issues because they're allowed to do
whatever the hell they want and nobody
cares and then we have this other group
that we kind of where at least we
pretend we care we do have yeah I think
that's a fascinating question I think
that a lot of times it starts with
groups that we already care about or
that we tend to see as our quote-unquote
enemies already right so we like to pick
scapegoats and we like to pick countries
to essentially pick on so if they've
already been in the media then it's it's
easier to latch on to that particular
group and continue that story and that
narrative than it is to bring up
something that you know we might not
know about our group that we might not
know about I think the narrative is that
so long as there's a leader a dictator
however they got into power if they're
murdering their own people we seem to
not give a right we seem to stay
out of it we seem to not want to get our
hands dirty with it the minute that
there's an insurgency there there's a
group that maybe has its tentacles in
multiple nations and for example like
Isis ISIL Islamic state whatever you
want to you call them now this
group you know until we did very little
about Syria as long as Assad was gassing
his own people I mean we did do some
diplomacy which was wonderful and I'm
glad that that happened now that Isis
has a foothold in Syria now we're
wanting to buddy up with Assad right we
also have we also have a strange
way of doing things if you kill people
with regular weapons we're okay with
that then Assad used chemical weapons
and Obama wanted to go to war just over
a year ago and and did in then Isis
starts beheading people now we go to war
by the way no congressional
authorization for any of this or any of
that stuff but that's a whole other
thing so final question on this when you
watch all this stuff does it make you
want to be an isolationist because
that's what I keep thinking when I watch
this stuff it makes me think we should
just pull out of the world altogether
even though it then leaves a vacuum
which causes all kinds of chaos and
that's what a lot of people are arguing
in Iraq right now we left and look what
happened well Chelsea Manning would
agree with you he came up with a state
you know he or she sorry
wrote a statement on how he believes she
believes gosh it's okay
I'm like trying to be politically grid
how she believes that we should pull out
and not intervene in the crisis with
ISIL or Isis and and feels that our
intervention there is the
well-intentioned only going to cause
more chaos instead it says we should
leave it alone and let Isis and their
regime sort of implode on itself so
Chelsea Manning would agree with you but
I think you bring up a fascinating
question which is do we as one of the
world's wealthiest nations have a
responsibility to intervene when other
countries are in need and to what extent
can we put a dollar figure on that
intervention and that's I think where
the question gets trickier I think we do
and I think we can't pick and choose the
way that we have previously I think that
we should be doing more in African
nations I think that we should be doing
more in places where individuals are
being subject to genocide I think the
big issue is that we need to think
further down the road we need to be
chess players not checkers
players and we need to realize that you
can't make strategic alliances that only
help you right now and then three years
later fight against those alliances this
is what happens to us all the time we
give military aid to nations and then
they we end up engaging in war with them
and they're fighting us with our own
weapons it's absolutely insane yeah and
just to be clear that's literally
happening right now we back the Muslim
Brotherhood in Egypt then they got
overthrown now we're back in the other
guy I mean the Taliban to fight the
Russians I mean it since we have it's
over and over and over and we don't seem
to be basically now Assad's Air Force we
were about to go to war with the Saud a
year ago and now we're his air force
against ISIL so yes it is a big freakin
mess there are no easy answers and well
I guess yeah a little chess would be
would be wise
[Music]